qu'est ce que la vie en voilà une belle
question philosophique et scientifique
qu'est ce qui fait la différence entre
ce qui est vivant et ce qui ne l'est pas
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'en pratique
un enfant de 10 ans n'aurait pas de mal
à vous donner des réponses montrez-lui
des photos et il vous dira qu'un chat et
un arbre son vivant n'est pas un caillou
ou une trompette ce qui est vivant bab
ça se voit non
enfin est ce que c'est si simple prenons
quelques cas un peu tordu
ce corail par exemple et bien malgré son
apparence de gros cailloux il s'agit
bien d'un organisme vivant
et ça n'est même pas une plante un il
fait partie du règne animal et la levure
chimique
alors non la levure chimique ça n'est
pas vivant c'est juste un mélange de
bicarbonate de soude et d'acide citrique
par contre la levure de boulanger et
bien ça c'est vivant si vous en observé
au microscope
vous verrez des cellules les levures
sont en effet des microorganismes
unicellulaire que l'on classe avec les
champignons un chat un concombre du
corail et de la levure de boulanger
malgré leur apparence extérieure si
différentes tous sont composés de
cellules vivantes et si on était capable
de plonger jusqu'à l'intérieur de ces
cellules de nager dedans on aurait
probablement un peu de mal à faire la
différence entre ces différents
organismes car toutes les cellules
vivantes partagent en effet un certain
nombre de traits communs si leur taille
peut varier beaucoup d'un organisme à un
autre et au sein du même organisme
toutes les cellules vivantes sont
délimités de la même façon par une
membrane fait d'une double couche de
lipides c'est une première
caractéristique commune à tous les êtres
vivre ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur de
ces cellules va évidemment dépendre de
l'espèce mais il existe un certain
nombre de processus que l'on retrouve à
l'identique que l'on parle d'un humain
d'un concombre ou d'une levure
les cellules ont par exemple besoin
d'énergie pour fonctionner et dans
l'ensemble du monde vivant cette énergie
est stockée par la même molécule l'atp
l'atp l'adénosine triphosphate de son
petit nom c'est une molécule qu'on
appelle parfois la monnaie énergétique
de la cellule chez tous les êtres
vivants
elle est au coeur du métabolisme en
étant sans cesse transporté consommer et
régénérée par les différents processus à
l'oeuvre dans une cellule
à cet instant dans votre corps
l'ensemble de vos cellules contiennent
au total quelques centaines de grammes
d'atp mais au cours d'une journée
c'est l'équivalent de votre poids en atp
qui sera consommée est produit par votre
corps la tp et son utilisation dans le
métabolisme
voilà donc un autre trait que l'on
retrouve chez tous les êtres vivants
qu'on connaît et puis bien sûr un autre
point commun à l'ensemble du monde
vivant c'est évidemment la dnc que l'on
molécules sert de support pour les gênes
grâce à la séquence de ses bases
les fameuses à gt c'est grâce à cet
alphabet rudimentaire l'adn permet le
stockage de l'information génétique dans
une cellule de concombres comme dans une
cellule dans et cavill l'adn est
constituée exactement la même façon et
on retrouve la même machinerie
cellulaire permettant notamment sa
réplication et son utilisation pour la
fabrication des protéines
en effet dans une cellule il existe des
milliers de protéines différentes ayant
chacune une fonction spécifique chaque
cellule doit donc savoir comment
fabriquer précisément les protéines qui
lui sont utiles et c'est là que l'adn
sert en quelque sorte de plan de montage
une protéine est toujours fabriqué comme
une chaîne de briques élémentaires qu'on
appelle les acides aminés
il en existe vingt différents qui
portent des petits noms le signe alanine
cystéine etc et le plan de montage d'une
protéine données c'est donc simplement
la liste des acides aminés qu'il faut
enchaîner pour la fabriquer pour faire
le lien entre l'adn et la liste d'acides
aminés qui composent une protéine il ya
un ensemble remarquable de règles qu'on
appelle le code génétique
le code génétique c'est ce tableau qui
indique comment à partir de la lecture
de la suite des bases de l'adn on peut
connaître la liste des acides aminés a
enchaîné pour faire une protéine donné
on lit les bases de l'adn par groupes de
trois et chaque groupe indique qu'elle
acides aminés ajouté à la chaîne et ce
tableau de conversion est le même chez
tous les êtres vivants de la levure
jusqu'à vous fait remarquable non avec
tous ces points communs on peut dire
qu'on a notre définition la vie c'est
tout ce qui est fait de cellules dans
lesquelles on trouve de l'adn
et pour lesquels le métabolisme utilise
la tp sauf que comme toujours quand on
essaye de formaliser une définition d'un
phénomène naturel ont fini par trouver
des choses qui sont à la frontière
prenons les virus contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser en regardant une
de ses représentations graphiques les
virus ne sont pas des cellules la
structure que l'on voit sur les images
de ce genre est ce qu'on appelle une
capside et elle est faite de protéines
et à l'intérieur des virus
on trouve uniquement de l'adn ou la rn
pas de machinerie cellulaire pas de
métabolisme et le principe d'un virus
c'est justement qu'il va devoir infectés
une cellule d'un autre organisme est
emprunté sa machinerie pour y faire
passer son adn
alors est-ce que les virus doivent être
considérée comme vivant et bien la
question fait débat entre les
spécialistes ou pourrait dire que oui
car ils ont de l'information génétique
sous forme d'adr ou des arn mais on
pourrait dire non car ils n'ont pas de
métabolisme et de capacité autonome à se
reproduire
et encore on peut trouver des exemples
toujours plus étonnants comme les virent
aux ide qui sont juste des morceaux
darren tout seul sans cap site pour les
entourer
ou bien les prions qui sont de simples
protéines ayant une capacité à
contaminer d'autres protéines en les
déformant
j'en avais déjà parlé dans un épisode
précédent sur le sujet
si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez aller
jeter un oeil donc notre définition de
la vie qui paraissait bien on pourrait
facilement la questionner sur la base de
ces exemples mais dans le fond pourquoi
est-ce qu'on aurait besoin d'une
définition précise de la vie est bien
faire l'exercice de réfléchir à une
définition de la vie peut avoir un
impact sur la façon dont on approche la
question des origines de la vie en effet
aujourd'hui on ne sait toujours pas
comment la vie est apparue sur terre il
y a trois ou quatre milliards d'années
qu'est-ce qui est le plus essentiel la
présence d'adn et darren le métabolisme
avec de l'atp les cellules délimité par
une membrane de lipides suivant
l'importance que l'on donne à ces
critères on n'envisagera pas la question
des origines de la vie de la même façon
la vie et elle est d'abord apparue dans
de l'eau douce qui sembleraient plus
propices à la formation de vésicules de
lipides ou bien dans des argiles qui
sont adaptés pour catalyser certaines
réactions biochimiques ou encore au fond
de l'océan dans des sources
hydrothermales idéal pour le métabolisme
chacune de ces hypothèses tu en as plus
m
l'accent sur l'un ou l'autre des aspects
qui caractérise la vie telle qu'on la
connaît mais au delà de la recherche des
origines de la vie sur terre
il existe bien sûr un autre domaine pour
lequel une définition de la vie est
absolument essentiel il s'agit de
l'astrobiologie la discipline qui
cherchent à savoir si la vie existe
ailleurs que sur terre et comment on
pourrait la détecter
[Musique]
quand on essaye d'imaginer à quoi
pourrait ressembler une forme de vie
extraterrestre on tombe assez vite dans
un travers classique on cela représente
comme une version un peu modifiée de la
vie telle qu'on la connaît sur terre de
la végétation verte des animaux
quadrupèdes des êtres intelligents
bipèdes
bref c'est en gros la vie sur terre qui
aurait juste évolué un peu différemment
et pourtant rien ne nous oblige à
imaginer la vie ailleurs comme un simple
copier coller de la vie sur terre
d'ailleurs si on s'intéresse à ce que
j'ai listé comme des essentiels de la
vie telle qu'on la connaît on peut
facilement imaginer des variations
biochimiques importantes
prenons les acides aminés qui
constituent nos protéines le terme
acides aminés en général désigne
n'importe quelles molécules fabriqués
selon un canevas précis qui est le
suivant un atome de carbone qu'on
représente souvent en position centrale
relié à un hydrogène un groupe et nages
2 la mine est un groupe coh l'acide d'où
le nom un acide aminé est sûre la
quatrième liaison du carbone eh ben on
met un peu ce qu'on veut enfin ski
chimiquement peut aller à cet endroit là
on appelle ça un radical si comme
radical vous mettez simplement un
hydrogène vous avez l'acide aminé qu'on
appelle la glycine avec un groupe ch 3
vous avez l'alanine un siège de s h la
cystéine etc des acides aminés qui
apparaissent dans le code génétique et
qui sont donc utilisés pour synthétiser
des protéines allemande vivant on l'a
dit il y en a 20 mai chimiquement on
peut en imaginer plein d'autres il
suffit de faire varier ce qu'on met
comme radical artificiellement on sait
d'ailleurs en synthétiser plusieurs
centaines d'autres alors pourquoi ne pas
imaginer des formes de vie qui se
baserait sur certains de ses autres
acides aminés
c'est d'autant plus attirant comme
hypothèse que l'on sait que beaucoup de
ces acides aminés sont assez faciles à
produire dans des conditions naturelles
on en a trouvé notamment dans des
expériences qui reconstitue les
conditions physico chimiques qui régnait
sur terre il ya 4 milliards d'années
comme dans la fameuse expérience de 1000
rr est encore mieux un certain de ces
acides aminés exotiques ont été
retrouvés dans des météorites comme la
météorite de murchison sommes tombés en
australie en 1969 on ya par exemple
identifier les acides aminés qu'on
appelle la normale in lysova line
et la sarcosine oui oui ça existe la
sarcosine aucun de ces acides aminés ne
fait partie de la liste des vingt mais
on pourrait très bien imaginer des
formes de vie alternative qui les
utilisent pour la synthèse des protéines
toutes ces variations autour de la
biochimie de la vie pourrait très bien
exister mais peut-être qu'on est encore
trop conservateur trop influencé par la
vie telle qu'on la connaît et s'il
fallait imaginer utiliser carrément des
réactions chimiques différentes ont déjà
vous le savez la vie sur terre est basé
sur l'eau l'eau sert de solvants ce à
dire de milieux liquides dans lequel
peuvent se dissoudre les différentes
molécules ce qui leur permet de se
rencontrer et de réagir mais on pourrait
imaginer d'autres solvants
j'avais parlé dans la vidéo sur l'eau
justement d'autres molécules comme
l'ammoniac nh3 et le méthane ch4
pourrait dans certaines conditions
servir aussi de solvants et donc de
milieux de base à de nouvelles formes de
vie on peut penser notamment à titan
c'est une lune de saturne qui fait à peu
près la moitié de la terre en diamètre
et qui possède des océans des nuages et
des rivières
mais au lieu d'être de l'eau c'est du
méthane liquide
il y assure titan tout un cycle du
méthane comme nous nous avons sur terre
un cycle de l'eau il se serait assez
tentant d'imaginer y trouvait des
organismes chimiquement très différent
de ce qu'on connaît pour pousser encore
plus loin on peut remarquer une chose
étonnante la quasi-totalité des
molécules qui interviennent dans la vie
sur terre sont constitués de seulement
six éléments carbone hydrogène oxygène
azote phosphore et soufre
on les appelle les shops et pour
fabriquer tout ce dont on a parlé
les protéines l'adn la rn les glucides
et les lipides ces six éléments là
suffisent
mais si on imaginait des biochimie
alternatives avec d'autres éléments
après tout il y en a plus d'une centaine
pourquoi se limiter à ces six là pour
nous aider à visualiser ça on peut se
servir du tableau de mendeleïev le voici
avec la position des six éléments dont
on a parlé les shops ce tableau vous
savez qu'on l'appelle aussi le tableau
périodique des éléments
et la raison c'est que dans une même
colonne du tableau on trouve des
éléments ayant un comportement chimiques
comparables la première colonne ce sont
les alcalin la deuxième les alkali noté
rela d
hier les gaz rares et c est donc en
général quand vous prenez un élément
l'élément situé en dessous de lui aura
de bonnes chances de former des liaisons
chimiques similaires et donc pour
trouver des alternatives aux shops on
peut peut-être aller piocher dans les
mêmes colonnes par exemple juste en
dessous du soufre on a le sélénium
c'est un élément peu abondants mais qui
chimiquement est très proche du soufre
pourquoi pas une forme de vie qui
l'utiliserait d'ailleurs de façon
intéressante c'est déjà un peu ce que
fait la vie sur terre
je vous ai dit qu'il n'y avait que 20
acides aminés qui entraient dans la
composition initiale des protéines et
bien il y en a en fait un 21e qui est
lassé les no cystéine c'est un acide
aminé en tout point identique à la
cystéine mais où l'atome de soufre a été
remplacé par un atome de sélénium et
comme chimiquement ces deux là sont très
proches
eh bien ça fonctionne cet acide aminé
non standard est assez rare et on le
retrouve même pas chez tous les êtres
vivants mais par exemple chez l'homme on
connaît une cinquantaine de protéines
qui l'utilisent comme quoi même la vie
sur terre arrive à faire des variations
de ces ingrédients de base
alors revenons au tableau périodique en
dessous du phosphore regarder on trouve
l'arsenic sa position nous dit que
chimiquement l'arsenic et le phosphore
peuvent avoir des comportements
analogues et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui
rend l'arsenic si dangereux en effet le
phosphore est un élément clé du
fonctionnement de la tp et de la
structure de l'adn et donc si un atom
d'arsenic vient prendre la place d'un
atome de phosphore
cela peut perturber le fonctionnement du
métabolisme ou encore la réplication de
l'adn
c'est pour cela que l'arsenic est à la
fois un poison est un cancérigène mais
si une nouvelle forme de vie se basait
complètement sur l'arsenic à la place du
phosphore chimiquement on se dit que ça
pourrait marcher
c'est d'ailleurs ce que certains ont cru
découvrir dans une bactérie il y a une
dizaine d'années alors la nouvelle a
fait grand bruit mais la découverte a
été contestée et finalement la
publication scientifique a été retiré la
vie à l'arsenic pas forcément sur terre
mais sur notre planète pourquoi pas
encore plus exotique en dessous du
carbone dans le tableau périodique il y
a le silicium
alors le carbone c'est vraiment
l'élément clé de la biochimie un car
avec ses quatre liaisons il peut former
tout un tas de molécules complexes et il
est donc à la base de toute la chimie
organique du vivre et c'est aussi grâce
aux liaisons du carbone que l'on peut
produire des matières plastiques les
plastiques sont en effet de longues
chaînes à base de carbone qui répète
sans cesse la même structure élémentaire
c'est ce qu'on appelle des polymères
mais le silicium avec ses quatre
liaisons potentiel peut dans une
certaine mesure jouer un rôle analogue à
celui du carbone c'est notamment ce qui
permet industriellement de fabriquer les
polymères qu'on appelle des silicones
qui sont des plastiques ayant des
propriétés différentes de se baser
uniquement sur le carbone
alors allons-y pourquoi pas une forme de
vie entièrement basé sur le silicium
après tout il s'agit d'un des éléments
les plus abondants sur une planète
rocheuse comme la terre et certains
organismes vivants savent d'ailleurs
déjà l'utiliser c'est le cas par exemple
des diatomées qui sont des
unicellulaires capable de se constituer
de magnifique coq est microscopique de
sio2 la silice elles se font en gros des
coquilles en verre naturel si on essaie
d'imaginer une forme de vie basé sur le
silicium ça voudrait dire que des
organismes pour est métabolisé des
molécules à base de silicium et
respirerait en rejetant non pas du co2
mais du siao 2l expirerait du vert donc
pour ma pourquoi pas
[Musique]
alors parmi tous les gens qui se sont
amusés à essayer de définir la vie de la
façon la plus large possible
il ya évidemment la nasa et ce tout
particulièrement depuis le début
d'émission en direction de mars et le
lancement des sondes viking en 1975
on comprend l'importance de la question
1 si l'ambition de ces missions est de
rechercher la présence de vie on a
plutôt intérêt à avoir une bonne
définition de ce qu'on appelle la vie
car évidemment ça va conditionner les
instruments qu'on voit embarquer les
analyses qu'on voudra faire et c'est
dans les années 90 un groupe de travail
de la nasa a justement proposé une
nouvelle définition de la vie qui a le
mérite d'être à la fois suffisamment
large et tout de même utilisable la vie
ce serait un système chimiques
auto-entretenue capable d' évolution
darwinienne dans cette définition tous
les mots sont importants
le mot système d'abord il montre bien
que la vie c'est pas tellement un truc
ici ou là c'est avant tout un système de
composants en interaction si on prend
une cellule et qu'on considère
indépendamment chaque molécule aucune de
ses molécules en particulier mais
vivante c'est le système dans son
ensemble qu'il l'est le mot chimiques
ensuite alors là on reste suffisamment
large sans supposer un rôle prépondérant
pour par exemple l'eau ou le carbone
très bien auto-entretenue attention ça
veut pas dire qu'un système vivant
capable de mouvement perpétuel
mais qu'il sait puiser dans son
environnement les ressources nécessaires
pour assurer son maintien au moins
provisoirement et enfin la partie la
plus intrigante capable d' évolution
darwinienne
c'est vrai qu'une des choses qui est
caractéristique de la vie sur terre
c'est bien la notion d'évolution au
moyen de la sélection naturelle
ce qu'avait compris darwin sans avoir
découvert le mécanisme chimique détaillé
qui se cachait derrière depuis darwin on
a compris que dans la vie sur terre
l'évolution est rendue possible par
l'adn c'est lui qui porte les gènes
c'est à dire l'information indispensable
à la notion d'évolution mais la
définition de la nasa laisse évidemment
la porte largement ouverte et permet
d'autres mécanismes que celui basé sur
l'adn
c'est d'ailleurs un exercice intéressant
de se demander de quoi on aurait besoin
chimiquement pour avoir quelque chose de
similaire à du stockage d'informations
génétiques pour qu'il y ait une
évolution darwinienne le
support chimiques de l'information doit
posséder deux propriétés la réplication
et les erreurs
prenez l'adn la raison pour laquelle
cette molécule permet les mécanismes
d'hérédité
c'est qu'elle est réplicable il est
chimiquement possible de recopier un
brin adn pour le passé à sa descendance
par exemple mais paradoxalement pour que
l'évolution darwinienne puisse avoir
lieu
il ne faut pas que cette copie soit
absolument parfaite il faut aussi des
erreurs sinon l'information serait
toujours copié à l'identique et les
organismes n'évoluerait jamais ce qui
permet l'évolution darwinienne ce sont
justement ces erreurs de copies les
mutations qui de temps en temps
donneront des descendants mieux adaptés
à leur environnement et qui seront donc
favorisé par la sélection naturelle pour
stocker comme ça une grande quantité
d'informations sur un support chimiques
il faut évidemment des molécules très
grande c'est ce qui se passe avec l'adn
et la rn elles sont constitués d'un
assemblage répétées de blocs
élémentaires ce sont donc des polymères
je voulais dire des polymères on en
connaît plein tous les plastiques dont
le nom commence par pauli quelque chose
ce sont des polymères qui peuvent être
très longs alors est-ce que n'importe
lequel de ses polymères pourrait
convenir pour stocker de l'information
génétique et bien probablement pas car
il ya une chose remarquable avec la
molécule d adn
si vous prenez votre adn et celui d'un
concombre on l'a dit la structure
globale est la même mais le détail est
évidemment très différent
la suite des bases à gtc qui les
constituent ne va pas du tout être
identique sinon vous seriez un concombre
et pourtant sur le plan physique ou
chimique
votre adn et celui d'un concombre se
comporte de manière parfaitement
similaires ils sont traités dans les
mêmes conditions par là-même machinerie
cellulaire
en gros ça veut dire que l'adn est une
molécule dont on peut changer carrément
des atomes sans pour autant affecter ses
propriétés physico-chimiques globale car
d'habitude ça marche pas ça si vous
prenez une molécule et que vous changez
certains atomes vous allez récupérer une
molécule qui n'est pas la même et qui
physiquement et chimiquement va
peut-être se comporter de façon
totalement différente
qu'est-ce qui fait cette sorte de
stabilité de l'adn le fait que quelle
que soit la séquence des bases ils se
comportent à l'identique
et bien d'après le biologiste stephen
venner l'ingrédient clé ce sont les
groupes phosphate que l'on retrouve dans
le squelette de l'adn et en particulier
le fait que ces phosphates soit chargé
négativement cette chaîne de charges
négatives dans le squelette joue un rôle
tellement dominant dans la détermination
des interactions physiques de la
molécule adn que peu importe les bases
qu on y attache la molécule réagi de la
même façon et cela a mené steven boehner
a proposé que pour stocker de
l'information génétique l'idéal c'était
d'avoir une molécule qui soit un
polymère dont les blocs élémentaire
porte des charges
ce qu'on appelle un poly électrolytes
donc pour lui pour identifier de la vie
ailleurs un système capable d' évolution
darwinienne
il faut chercher des traces de poly
électrolytes steven boehner a d'ailleurs
lui-même essayer d'en fabriquer de façon
synthétique pour démontrer comment créer
des alternatives à la bn qui ne soit pas
de l'adn c'est ainsi qu'en 2019
il a publié un exemple de poly
électrolytes pouvant servir de support
d'information et comportant huit base au
lieu des 4 dont on a l'habitude avec
toutes ces considérations
on peut se dire qu'on a maintenant une
définition de la vie qui nous permettent
de rechercher des choses de façon
suffisamment large sans tomber dans le
piège de chercher quelque chose qui
ressemble trop à la vie sur terre telle
qu'on la connaît mais si on était encore
trop restrictif et si la vie pouvait
prendre des formes qui nous échappent
complètement qui s'affranchissent
carrément de la chimie telle qu'on
envisage en 1964 alors que la nasa se
posait ses premières questions sur
comment définir la vie pour l'identifier
le chimiste james lovelock leur avait
dit si j'étais vous pour trouver de la
vie je chercherai des réductions
d'entropie à l'entropie lorsqu une
notion qu'on associe souvent au désordre
et dont le deuxième principe de la
thermodynamique nous dit qu'elle ne peut
qu'augmenter dans l'univers le désordre
va croissant et pourtant on dirait que
l'émergence de la vie il s'affranchit
deçà des structures de plus en plus
ordonné de plus en plus organisé de plus
en plus complexes est ce que la vie va à
l'encontre des lois de la
thermodynamique
j'avais un tout petit peu évoqué ces
questions dans mon épisode sur l'énergie
et l'entropie et j'avais promis de vous
faire une suite sur la thermodynamique
de la vie et bien voilà les bases sont
posées et dans le prochain épisode
on se demandera donc comment on peut
définir la notion de vie à partir de
considérations thermodynamique
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner si vous aimez ce
contenu hl pour
rien rater vous pouvez aussi retrouver
les actualités de la chaîne sur facebook
et sur twitter
et puis on se retrouve bientôt pour la
suite de cette exploration de la vie
[Musique]